[Music]
all right let's go to ophelia in
asheville north carolina what's up
ophelia
hi how are we doing
oh you know hanging in there
oh you know
oh man
so what's going on
um so i
am calling to see how to reconnect with
my husband after i broke up with my
boyfriend
this will be good go ahead fill me in
yeah so
i don't know blame covid or deployments
or that my ace score of six i don't know
we
had marriage problems and we thought the
way to fix it was to go to polyamory
with other people who
were more emotionally connected and
that obviously ended in a great big ball
of burning fire yeah tell me about
so first tell me about how y'all came to
that conclusion who came to who
so i came to him i was presented with
the offer from a mutual friend of ours
and
because i was talking to him about our
problems and
he was like i'll sleep with you
basically yeah i'll sleep with you i'll
be your emotional connection i
you know that will be great for all of
us i'll take one for the team
exactly
hey what a great guy um fantastic a lot
of people in the world that would have
just
not done that and but man
wow and so you sit down with your
husband and you're like so i've got an
offer for you how'd that go
um at first he's like i don't understand
why and then he was like well i can have
someone as well so we might as well just
try it and then
it was about six months of like lust
puppy love happiness of yeah i can
have attention when my husband's not
giving me any and then it ended up being
that the person treating me like
terribly and then i broke it off and now
we're trying to just kind of stand here
in the ashes like well now what do we do
did your husband date anybody
yeah he did
and uh how does that sit with you
at the time i didn't care i was just
happy that we could all be doing this
like amicable adults like quotation
marks around that and then
now i don't like it as much now that i'm
realizing i still want to be with my
husband and
want to fix all the things that are
broken in our relationship
so what is broken in your relationship
um it's
more of the lack of emotional connection
we got married at 18 and didn't know who
we were or what was happening and i had
a bunch of childhood trauma that i've
been in therapy now for two years
finally working through and now that i'm
getting healthier i want to actually
turn around and like fix the issues in
my relationship rather just being in
survival mode
and how's your husband doing
um
you know he's just there he's
he's started therapy finally he's more
than just there
here's the thing he watched his wife
come and say listen you're not meeting
this need for me
i think i found like this really giving
kind guy said he would be happy to step
in
and have none of the emotional support
and all of the sexual intimacy support
again great guy world class
and
um
and then he watched you go off and and
basically fall in love with somebody
yeah and yeah he hung around at home
how's he doing now
um he hasn't actually talked about it
really i mean he said that he was okay
with it when it was happening and i was
very honest about all of these feelings
and emotions and anytime he wanted
details about like
weekends we spent together something i
would tell him and
he hasn't said anything i can't honestly
say i've asked though
yeah yeah i was asking my question does
he have permission to speak into that or
two
i'm just trying to roll through that in
my mind and
like sitting down with my wife and
having that conversation and i imagine
everything would be so compressed i
would i think my body would take over at
that point and just numb me out you know
what i mean
like that'd be the only way to get
through the day
um
so here's my
is that
give me give me let me before i give you
my beliefs um give me a
describe to me what you felt with this
new person in month one
um
like i was happy that i
was getting attention and that somebody
was underneath that
like um i mean there was shame honestly
underneath it underneath that i'm not
looking for negative things i'm um okay
like what did you feel
i mean i didn't eat for two weeks if
that's what you're asking
no
the most common
word that we hear in this in this world
when somebody cheats on somebody when
somebody um even has like agreed
non-monogamy for a season
the word most common heard is the word
alive
i felt alive again
yeah and
it feels so it's just like cocaine it's
fireworks it's cotton candy it's the
greatest feeling after feeling
quote-unquote not alive for so long
i don't think this had anything to do
with this other guy
at all
i think it had everything to do with you
and for some reason in the relationship
you are currently in your marriage
you've chosen
death
and then for some reason you chose
life
with somebody who's abusive and took
advantage of you
and
i'm not saying all people take advantage
of all people but this guy clearly saw
an opportunity and
um
am i right he didn't treat you well
right
right yeah i mean at first it felt like
it and then no
yeah
so
um but that even even your willingness
to take that sort of this some of this
is really great and some of this is
terrible but
it all felt alive
right
and so my question to you is why are you
choosing
to not be alive in your marriage
because life's so short man we get one
shot
i think we just got complacent
we
i mean we've
known each other basically our entire
lives and we stopped trying
and i didn't think that we could go back
to trying so
this other avenue looked really good
and so now you're back to wanting to try
again tell me what you've tried
when's the last time you slept with with
somebody else
over a year ago okay so
um
y'all called it off right you said no
that was a terrible idea
i just yeah and then we tried to stay
friends for a bit and that obviously
didn't work either so then it's been
about four months since
all communication stopped okay so now
you and your husband have y'all called
this off
yes okay and so now you're staring at
each other being like so
what now
yeah what have you tried
um we went to a marriage retreat
together and didn't really get anything
out of that
um
we have a vacation planned to iceland
later like in the fall time
um
that's yeah that's pretty much it
so you just gave me two more
firework shows
and you need to hear me say that's not
how desire is built
okay those are fun i mean
i mean don't get me wrong those are fun
and a blast and it's cool to shake the
snow globe up and it's cool to change
environments that's all great
this is a daily choice that i want to be
alive
i want to be
alive in my skin
this is a daily choice that me and this
guy are going to sit across the table
and say
we got one shot at this we did something
stupid it didn't help us at all and now
we're living in the ash of this so what
we're going to do is we're going to
start this thing over which is awesome
and we're going to build something
totally new
and the cool thing about it is you get
to build something totally new but you
got to stop with the well i guess we
just quit trying and we've known each
other for life all that crap none of it
matters i could care less about any of
it
everything
is about what are we going to do
tomorrow
and what are we going to do today you
know what i mean because you you come
bearing all these excuses
and honestly i don't care about your
aces score i do because i love you and
you know i love talking about trauma and
stuff we could have that conversation
all these things you're working through
which is fantastic
at some point you have to decide i'm
worth living
alive in my own skin which means i'm
gonna work i'm worth living alive in my
relationships
which means
i'm worth when things are a little
running a little bit low that's okay
because it's cold outside
and i'm going to have some communication
and some practices with my husband that
we know how to turn the heat back up
when it's time and until you can make
and that's hard that's what i like
that's adult stuff it's tough man it's
boring it's day after day after day and
holy crap it's worth it it's worth every
step of the way
if he'll play along will he play
yeah he will he
but he's so
into keeping the relationship going i
think that that was part of it too is
that he wanted to keep me happy and so
he agreed to it so you're gonna have to
process that shame and say that out loud
have you told him that because here's
the thing now you're gonna start beating
yourself up over it
yeah
right
yep completely
and he doesn't need
yet another
you don't need this you know what i mean
yeah so can you forgive you
can you forgive y'all and put a period
at the end of it and then go excavate
this thing and build something new
i'm going to have to
i can't build anything on shame
you're right but millions and millions
and millions and millions of people do
okay
i guess just what's the practical steps
then i don't know if i've ever been
taught how to live in the
everyday yeah
so here's some practical stuff the first
thing is
before you go on like another marriage
retreat or something spectacular here's
the thing those things come with a lot
of pressure
and if they're still smoldering ash that
pressure can it can just lead to
something combustible
okay and so when i'm gonna enter into
like if my wife and i gonna go to a
retreat of some sort we've got a plan as
to what we're going in to get out of
this thing
if we're going on vacation like we talk
about in our house what's this fake do
we need this just to be a reckless
wheels off weekend together do we need
just do you need to sleep and i just i'm
gonna go for hikes or what like we are
really intentional about what the plan
is otherwise we both go in with
different plans and then we both go in
different plans we have different
fantasies about what's going to be on
the back end of this thing we're all
going to be all in love again no we're
not that guy just slept the whole
weekend
or we're gonna have crazy sex all
weekend we're gonna reconnect and find
not really just wanna go to a movie i'm
tired right and my knee hurts like
whatever the thing is
and so you have to be super intentional
way in advance and so okay here's what
it looks like number one it looks like
you being honest with the shame and
honest with the secrets
and either there's a couple of things
you haven't told him yet
not talking about gory details about
whatever we can get away or whatever i'm
not talking about that
i'm talking about
you this is a terrible idea and you knew
it while you were in it and you need to
say that out loud
or
it what you don't think it was a
terrible idea and you gave it a shot and
then you realized halfway through
you just be honest shame eats secrets
for breakfast
so there's got to be a season of honesty
and you have to give him a safe space to
be honest too
okay and he will probably say things
that are hard to hear is that fair
totally fair okay
have you been totally honest with him
100
yeah i have okay then this will be about
creating a space for him to talk and
then here's the goal
what are your needs so i'm going gonna
ask you that what do you need
what makes you feel alive what made you
feel alive
being feeling seen by the person seeing
that i was having a rough day without
actually saying it or
that my family went off on one of their
drunken tangents again and i could
actually express my emotions to the
person and have them be supportive like
i need to feel seen and supported okay
here's what a great gift is and this is
not in any hollywood movie okay
okay you being really clear with him
about what being seen looks like
okay and
in the moment
when you are not feeling seen you say it
not angry and not out of rage but out of
you're a teacher and it's a gift this is
a moment when
i need you just to come hug me and sim
so sorry your day was hard and say
nothing else
okay
okay the same as you gave this other
knucklehead um that benefit of the doubt
like i like this in bed or i like that
you taught him those things teach your
husband the important stuff okay
okay fair
fair and he gets to tell you what he
needs and by the way being seen is just
one because being seen is part one of i
need you to see all of me and please
still love me and for a kid with a six
on the aces score a lot of people have
had their way with you
both emotionally and otherwise
and you have a
spinning
uh
like a fusion center in your heart that
tells you what you're worth
and it is one percent of what the truth
is okay
okay am i right
yes yeah you are okay
so
you're gonna have to let him tell you
what his needs are and you can't fly off
the handle and you can't shut down
right
run away that's me there we go you go
hide there you go you can't shut down
you got to stay present with them and
say i need you to teach me will you walk
alongside me in this
and then you're going to have to in the
same conversation
preferably over a meal i like him over a
meal that's just me because i like
eating when i'm sad and that's not a sad
thing i just i just eat my feelings and
so there we go
so
you don't have to you can do it on a
hike or whatever
um and then you have to say
in one year
i want to
this to feel and look like this
in two years in five years i want this
thing to look like this this thing being
our marriage and if our marriage is not
alive it's just a reflection of what i'm
putting into it
and reflection of what he's putting into
it
okay okay
so hear me say this
um
i know of no quality data
that suggests an open marriage solves
anything
i just have i haven't seen the data it
makes no sense okay um i've seen some
crappy crappy studies and i know it's
super cool to talk about with like yeah
bro we're adults we can just be adult
that's just stupid
you know what i mean i also told myself
when i turned like was an adult that i
could eat taco bell every day and that
was a terrible choice too i'm an adult
bro i can just do whatever i want not
great right
and so here's the deal
um
you have to decide what we want this
thing to look like and you're going to
reverse engineer it you're going to be
curious with each other and be patient i
do think
um
if you're both invested in this thing
you can have an extraordinary marriage
moving forward i really believe that
okay but you have to decide he's worth
it and you have to decide
that you are worth it
he can't materialize into your soul mate
he's going to become your soul mate
after 25 years of grinding things out
and if y'all rebuild something beautiful
and powerful and strong
man
then you look back and say look what we
did together and he's gonna be like
remember that time you and you're gonna
be like shut up stop we're not talking
about it
right okay okay yes yeah it's totally
fair okay okay all of this starts with
you getting with your counselor that
you're still seeing and say i'm i'm
tired of carrying these bricks of shame
around we're going to start working on
setting them down some of that will be
about writing something that will be
about um
you know they'll have a process with you
with your therapist every therapist
works with shame and if they don't god
help you go get another therapist
okay but this is gonna be about building
something together with him and hearing
me say you are worth
a marriage that is alive
practice desire
it is a practice what do you need what
are the ons and offs so here's two
things i'm gonna send you a copy of own
your past change of future my new book
so stay on the line here and i also want
you to get a copy of
emily nagoski's book come as you are
um it's a book about sex and intimacy
for women but it's incredible for i i've
just found a really invaluable resource
um there's probably a lot of stuff in
there that you don't need to hear but
there's some incredible sections on offs
and ons and gas pedals and breaks in
this idea about sexuality and intimacy
and how to have conversations together
inside of a marriage
um and there's gonna be stuff in there
you don't like blow like move on past it
it's like all books are gonna be that
way you can find stuff in my book that
you don't like too my book's going to
walk you through okay you've got a mess
you got to own it and then now what are
you going to do moving forward and it'll
give you a blueprint for moving forward
there and her book will give you some
conversations to have with your husband
and he needs to read it too right
thank you for being honest and
set the bricks down man
let's excavate this whole thing and
let's start anew let's build something
beautiful